The world’s largest bioluminescent area
an area so big you can see it from space
went unknown to science until 2005
This was common sailor lore
that sometimes you would sail into these areas where the sea was white
and light was glowing up from below the ship
The reason scientists didn’t know about it
is that they didn’t think it was possible for that many micro organisms
to be in one place, doing something together
but they were wrong
So how did the milky seas finally get spotted by science?
Well, Google helped
In 2005 a scientist named Steve Miller was musing over lunch
whether it would even be possible for a light sensing satellite
to see bioluminescence in the ocean
he got home and he started Googling
He came across a 1995 report from the SS Lima
The exact words are
“The bioluminescence appeared to cover the sea horizon to horizon “
Luckily for Steve Miller as he matched the report from the SS Lima
with the satellite data
a very clear image began to resolve
There was in fact a corresponding area of bioluminescence
that was enormous!
This was the first hard proof of the Milky Seas
The bacteria they think causes the milky seas
is a bacteria called Vibrio Harveyi
it doesn’t want to scare off predators it wants to attract fish
because the place it wants to live is on the inside of a fish
So the amount of bacteria it would take to make a glowing area the size of Connecticut
is almost unfathomable
it is forty billion trillion bacteria
if each bacteria were the size of a grain of sand
the grains of sand would cover the earth ten centimeters deep
the whole earth, all of it
what causes this? The truth is they don’t know
We don’t know yet how it forms
we don’t know what the conditions are
But what we do know is that it does happen
and you know who else knew it? Jules Verne
In 20,000 leagues under the sea he describes the SS Nautilus
coming across this phenomenon
It’s likely that Jules Verne used real ships logs to describe the milky seas
while it may have taken science until 2005
to find definitive proof of the milky seas
Jules Verne was eerily scientifically accurate in 1869
Subscribe Here
and watch more videos here
Siri when was 20,000 Leagues Under The Sea published?
The answer is one thousand eight hundred and sixty nine
If you have places you’ve traveled
that you thought were just the most amazing thing you have ever seen
hidden wonders you would like to share with us
please, let us know in the comments, follow us on twitter and tell us there
let us know on Facebook, we would love to hear about them